hi everyone I'm here with Yuna who's a
founder of locket and I'll also be
speaking to her co-founder akashic later
in the course you know can you tell me a
little bit about locket and sort of how
you got started
sure so it's a company that's two years
old I used to work at an investment bank
and that was my first job out of college
and the idea was you know this lock
screen that were staring at 150 times
per day
it's nothing better than just a photo in
a clock currently can we do something
better than that it was the idea so then
I quit my job promptly and then I
started you know building the team so
that's where I found my co-founder
Kashuk and then we moved into a
two-bedroom apartment where I lived with
five other guys and three dogs and I'm
living out of the living at the bedrooms
and I'm working out of the living room
so that how we started and the v1 model
was - hey Kim can we show ads on the
lockscreen and you'll get paid from
advertisers and pay users to just rent
out their lockscreen so that was our
initial start started off as like a very
you know ramen noodle startup like kind
of like a project and it just like
suddenly became a company after we like
started fundraising and such great and I
was like the early user adoption how did
you guys start finding users and getting
getting that traction it was very abrupt
we thought that we would get like 10,000
users in the first month and that's how
we like calculated all the all these
other like ad sales and all that stuff
we ended up getting 25,000 users on the
first day and then we ended up getting
like a million users from that v1 model
which ended up failing so which is why
we pivoted into a different model which
is showing content on the lockscreen
that app is launched it's called locket
and it's launching the Google Play Store
and it will show relevant news on your
lock screen so like and every time you
wake up your phone I'll show different
news so that you're like keeping them
now okay and and so you originally had
the product which was ad space and then
you moved into news because he thought
that was a big attraction it was
something that was in demand and people
wanted so the way in which like our
thought process worked was we couldn't
pay
so when we were doing the paper ad swipe
model what happened was we because we
got so many users in a short period of
time it was impossible for us to plan
out the next ad cycle because we like
without knowing how many like millions
of users will have the next month it was
impossible to sell the ads in advance
and also not only that because
advertisers pay us three months but
months after the ad campaigns have been
finished so we were in business of
paying users first before getting paid
from advertisers yeah so we needed to
raise a lot of like millions of dollars
and we're just like three months old
company yeah so we had to make a
decision okay we're not gonna do this
anymore
then what is the other type of value
that we can provide on the lockscreen
and the idea was okay we just tried out
the economics model which is like paying
and rewarding users can we deliver like
the right content at the right time and
delight users that way and and then you
know we were pivoting we showed like we
were just testing out by showing some of
these other articles like Justin Bieber
I just went to jail or like you know did
you know that this airplane had XYZ and
the engagement on those articles were
really great so then we went to talk to
these media companies who wanted to
partner us in order to distribute the
content so that's how I got the
transition in which we conveyed and also
use their base change a little bit too
because when we were paying users it was
a users that really value that 3 to 5
dollars per month but as as we were
moving towards the content model is the
the users that are hungry to learn more
and just like these compounds yeah
interesting